hi I am James Marshall with the help of
my friends I've been training for the
2013 math and to sob now that's all done
so let's get on with it
after day one I was feeling pretty
shitty I didn't sleep and had bad
diarrhea 22 runners have already dropped
out no matter how bad it gets I'm not
joining them this is not an ordinary man
today it's very very steep as you can
see we've come where we are one mountain
down the other pop another it is
exhausting but this is the mouth of the
SOB and why we've come as to this epic
race it was easy everyone would do with
me today the day - and I've seriously
underestimated a nap and sob you know
like for like such a [ __ ] buddies it's
like overpowering not overwhelming pains
I mentioned - mine is he uh
so debugger today
we keep hydrated drank about eight
liters of water - water and peatones not
a good sign
this is a really beautiful silver
village and a real oasis look at that
welding it desert hot enough running you
there's a cow my own [ __ ] tight now then
I put Mounties in a river right in the
course but yeah it's a good day I think
with now we've now done three stages and
we have two stages to go I'm terrified
about tomorrow tomorrow's the eighty
kilometers or 50 miles and apparently
there's 13 kilometers of enormous sand
dunes so I would give myself hopefully
I'll do tomorrow station at 18 hours but
I'm absolutely knackered I think I might
go to bed to me so yeah so day three
down two more to go going now for what
nine hours nine hours exactly the gun
outfit going for nine hours Suns coming
down
we've got 30 K or 20 miles to go my feet
as well as my friends feet are wrecked
the second we get up I don't I dare take
my shoes off because I think there's you
know they're swollen in there bloodied
now is falling off it's gnarly and
disgusting
oh okay well Shane right now I don't
think I've ever looked to be it's
probably fluid lifted the mail
oh that is gross dude now this is what
the mouth and sob does to your feet as
my mouth completely off when the scalp I
cut into my soul it was pretty bad for
the wronskian just had to go
they took 15 percent of the skin from my
left foot and 20% from the right foot
and I still have to run a full mouth and
tomorrow
sir
I can walk without shoes on it's just
walking putting my shoes on so what
makes you think you're doing is taking
if it gets really bad my shoes taking my
insoles out of my shoes and it's get
some tape and taping sort of got my
things
give us their 590 it's like Bloods
advanced notice this bit
the chest oh yes
0:07
okay
the mountain is finally over thank God
it's been
emotional it's been a painful it's been
the most challenging you've ever done
someone asked me today what I ever do it
again and I really can't say a word
maybe a change of mind in a few weeks
but we've had
a guy had a flare blob return yesterday
I hope you were heading back to off the
of the race course
one of our friends almost died yesterday
I need to fluid pumped into him it's
been 52 degrees Celsius
it's just been
I just cannot describe what it's like
you